[Music]
so the big ship is not stuck anymore
which is kind of cool there was this big
cargo ship like a quarter mile long and
it was stuck in the suez canal it
created this huge traffic jam
blocking one of the world's most
important shipping lanes they spent days
trying to dig it out it was costing like
400 million dollars
an hour for the global economy and now
it's not stuck
but i can't stop thinking about it
because this
ship and it being stuck for a few days
reminds us
just what the global economy is and how
important
one little strip of water can be both
for the economy but also for countries
who want power
so i gotta tell you an insane story
about this canal it was the 1960s
and the u.s government was thinking
about using
520 nuclear bombs to make a new canal
for themselves right here next to the
suez canal
we're talking over 100 kilometers of a
new canal to connect the mediterranean
to the red sea using nuclear bombs
what oh my gosh it's so insane like it's
so
insane this was gonna cost like five
billion dollars in today's terms and the
idea here was to create a strategically
valuable
alternate to the present-day suez canal
to understand why the u.s would even
consider
blowing up 520 nukes in the israeli
desert you have to understand this
little strip
of water and why it has been so vital to
so many powerful countries over the
years
first let's look at a map
this is an amazing project from
shipmap.org where each
dot represents a cargo ship similar size
to like the empire state building each
of these ships is carrying
around a thousand containers like 25 000
tons of stuff
[Music]
these ships fuel our lifestyles a good
example
is your iphone if you have one before
you ever see your iphone there is an
amazing journey that it goes on
every individual part of your iphone has
its own little story
they're sourced from 43 different
countries on all six continents
there's no way it could go into every
single component but let's just take one
thing the processor the sort of
brain of your iphone the processor
starts as raw materials
tons of raw materials like boron from
turkey or copper from chile or tantalum
from rwanda
and way way more that are mined in
different countries and
ship to a factory in taiwan where it is
manufactured and then shipped to the
philippines to be tested
and packaged before it is then shipped
to china to be integrated into your
phone
and that is just for the little
processor in your iphone not to mention
the screen
and the casing and the camera each one
of these has components that are sourced
from
all around the world they go through
this complex journey to then be
assembled and then
get put back onto a shipping container
to be shipped to your country where you
can buy it
no matter how i put it saying it's a
complex global supply chain
there's no way we can even fathom just
how
big and massive these operations are the
amount of space
of ocean that these products pass
through to eventually make it into our
hands
and this is everything my clothing my
computer my camera equipment everything
around me
passes through this system to add
another layer of weird complexity the
ships themselves like the physical ships
are also mind-bendingly complex so let's
take the ever given this ship that was
stuck in the suez canal recently this
ship is chartered by
a taiwanese company okay but it is
registered in panama
i've talked about ship registration in a
different video by the way and why ships
want to be registered in different
countries anyway it is registered in
panama charted by a taiwanese company
but
the ship itself the physical ship is
owned by a japanese company which is
owned by a bigger conglomerate of
ship builders oh and the technical
manager on board is it actually a german
guy
and the crew are a bunch of indian
nationals
i mean this ship itself is just a symbol
of how
big and convoluted and multi-layered
this huge global system
is okay so that's the global economy
let's get back to the suez canal
take a look at this canal for like five
seconds and you realize that it's not
natural way too straight of lines but
back before it was built if you wanted
to get
from europe to asia you had to sort of
do this
back then the british controlled this
little port in south africa which gave
them
a very nice strategic advantage because
everyone who was doing world trade
or domination had to pass through them
the british were loving this monopoly
over the trade route until like the
mid-1800s
when the french went to the egyptians
and they said hey is there any way we
could like
dig out a canal right here on this land
bridge that connects
africa with asia it's almost 200
kilometers long
but if we could just dig out a canal
here we would save
thousands of kilometers on each trip to
asia reminder this is like the 1860s and
like they don't have
loads of fancy equipment to do this but
they try it anyway
with over a hundred thousand people many
of them forced laborers
working on this canal for over 10 years
they were able to dig
this big canal that connected the
mediterranean sea
to the red sea the british were down
here
still like wait why is no one coming
through our cape anymore and the french
were up here just
laughing feeling so good about their new
canal
so over the years quickly this becomes
the epicenter of
water control and balance of power
control over the canal is mainly
french and egyptian for most of its time
but eventually the british just like
couldn't help themselves they needed
in on this waterway fast forward a few
years and all of the big powers get
together and say like whoa whoa whoa we
built this canal with a spirit of
cooperation
and neutrality all countries should be
able to use this canal
even in times of war everything will be
peaceful
and wonderful and this will be one no no
no no no
they signed this treaty about like
neutrality and everyone can use it but
let's just say it right now that's not
the way the world works
soon the globe descended into world war
and it became clear that this canal
would not be neutral anytime soon hitler
wanted it
so him and his italian allies went down
to try to take it over
british fought back and they were able
to keep it and there were british troops
there so the canal
remained in british control until like
the 1950s when finally egypt was like
okay listen
france britain this has been fun this
whole pretend that this is neutral but
it's not actually neutral and you're
actually just using it for whatever you
want thing
you're done it is our canal get out of
here and he's like oh and
israel um you can't come here and use
our waterway
either that's part of this so france and
britain aren't feeling super great they
just got kicked out of like their
key strategic waterway they decide to
say no and they send in a bunch of
paratroopers to the suez canal
along with israel's fighters to
recapture the canal from egypt and to
overthrow
the government that just kicked them out
and the u.s has seen all of this and
they're like guys it's not 1850
anymore okay times have changed you
can't just show up wherever you want and
just take it over militarily we don't do
that anymore that's so like old school
empire
but the us says you can still be an
empire in these times
you just have to be a little smoother
about it good baby
so the u.s sends in this canadian guy to
settle the conflict over the canal and
everyone's sort of like okay fine and
the canal goes back to peace with like
some u.n
peacekeepers to keep it at peace kind of
well no this isn't gonna last so this is
where the u.s
gets it creative and is like what can we
do to not have to like fight over the
canal but like do our own thing and
that's when the nuclear bombs come up
where they're like if we just plant 520
nuclear bombs here in the israeli desert
we could just have our own canal and
then we don't have to fight over this
one
so it's 1967 and israel's like i'm not
super into the idea of you like nuking
our desert but we like nuclear weapons
and we'll totally get on board with that
in the meantime can we go in and attack
egypt ourselves and get the canal and
you can just sort of back us from the
sidelines and the u.s is like
okay fine
[Music]
so israel goes in and takes over all of
this land all the way up to
the suez canal so it's egypt on one side
israel on the other
and for the next few years this becomes
a literal
battleground for multiple wars like they
were building bridges across the canal
to like
bring in tanks and fight oh and of
course during these years of fighting
from like the late 60s to the mid 70s
the canal was closed for obvious reasons
the problem is when they closed it there
were 15 ships that were like
in process of moving through and those
ships just got stuck there
for literally eight years so yeah ever
given we know that it was a hard few
days
how the world was super worried about
you 400 million dollars a day imagine
being one of these guys
eight years at least they had fun during
their time i guess
okay do you see where i'm going with
this what i'm trying to do here is not
give you a history lesson of the suez
canal
i'm trying to explain that this stretch
of water has always been a magnet
for international conflict ever since
its very very
conception after that last war the u.s
is like
okay broke her apiece they broke her
apiece and then they bring in these
helicopters to the sewers canal
with like a water sled behind them and
they drag them along
the water because there was a bunch of
like live explosives from the wars and
they were trying to like rid them all so
that they could resume
you know like normal shipping lanes they
eventually did that they got rid of all
the explosives
and reopened the canal in 1975 and the
canal remained peaceful
and under the control of its rightful
owner the egyptians
forevermore and there was no more
conflict or geopolitical scheming ever
again
[Music]
no that isn't the way the world works
yes things have changed in the way that
we do it
but the fact is when you have a system
like this
and a large portion of that system which
is
money and control and economics and
energy runs through
a choke point in that system there will
always be
geostrategic value that is put on that
system not just for economics
but for power so do you think that the
united states who's sort of the big boy
world policeman right now
would sit here and let egypt control the
chokehold where 12 percent of the world
economy passes through
including loads of oil no that's not how
it works despite the fact that egypt is
a non-democratic regime that is pretty
terrible on all fronts including human
rights the u.s
still provides 1.4 billion dollars of
military aid
to egypt every year they are always
considered a key
ally in the middle east i mean the
clinton administration
made it very clear that the reason we
support egypt
is because they have the suez canal and
we need them to owe us favors that
continues today whenever a us
military vessel shows up to the suez
canal they get to cut in line and go
through quicker than everybody else
so yeah egypt owns the canal but really
it's the u.s behind the scenes that is
keeping
everything in order the canal is not
neutral it will never be neutral
there will always be geopolitical
importance placed on it
and as long as there's a superpower that
superpower will control the canal
the last thing i'll say here is that we
live in a world that
is very strange for how peaceful it is
we've had an enduring peace for many
many decades that peace
allows us to have a system like this
and that peace exists partly because we
are so
entangled with one another economically
that it doesn't make sense to go to war
but we have to remember that that piece
also exists because all the big powers
have really big weapons that are always
pointed at each other if something slips
or escalates a little
too far just remember that the suez
canal isn't the only
choke point on earth where all of this
system flows through and that while we
take peace for granted now
it would be naive not to wonder what
happens if
that were to go away and we were faced
with not just one ship being stuck for a
few days
but an entire region militarized and
unavailable for this type of shipping
flow that we're so used to
and for years i don't want to sound
alarmist but i do want us to be
thinking about our reliance on this
system and what it means
for the future of rising powers that may
not want to cooperate
as well as they do today so when i see
ever given
blown off course for a few days and
everyone freaking out about it i don't
just see one ship i see
a vulnerable system and i see myself
and how deeply connected i am to that
system
so i'm listening to an audio book right
now
called silence shusaku endo
is the author and it's about like a
catholic missionary in japan
like in maybe the 15th or 1600s maybe
the 1700s i don't know a long time ago
i'm listening to it on audible
which is the sponsor of today's video
which i can't really believe i'm saying
because
i've been subscribed to audible since
like 2011 or 2012 like right when they
first came out
and it has changed my entire world so
the fact that they're sponsoring this
video and supporting my channel
is a very exciting thing for me and i'm
still kind of giddy about it anyway
audible is a giant repository of
audiobooks
and podcasts and all sorts of
audio resources that have changed my
life
i'm always listening to several
audiobooks on audible at any given time
sometimes it is
historical fiction sometimes it is like
fantasy stuff oftentimes i will be
listening to an audiobook about
some video i'm working on like russia or
american expansion
there's so much to learn on this app so
you can do a month of audible for free
if you want
there's a link in my description it is
audible.com johnny harris
you can also text johnny harris to the
number 500 500. clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you
a month of free audible what i love
about an audible membership is
that you get an audio book every month
you can choose whatever
audiobook you want no matter how
expensive it is you get it for
the one flat fee that you pay every
month and then you get unlimited access
to
all of these original titles like the
original content that they produce
there's tons of stuff i use this stuff
for like my kids too
and i get it for free because i'm an
audible member it's a very good deal so
link in my description audible.com
johnny harris or text my name to this
number
and you can get in on this deal i just
love audible because i love learning
and it allows me to learn a lot more
because i'm not very good at reading
because i'm dyslexic and that's a whole
other story okay
thank you all for being here i will see
you in the next one
you